was a promise made in 2019 we will build
40 new hospitals reiterated in 2020 40
more between now and 2030. repeated last
year we Mr Speaker are helping to build
another 40 new hospitals and again in
2022. they constantly say that we're not
going to build 40 new hospitals Mr
Speaker well I can tell him although we
are the prime minister at one of those
new hospitals in Leeds just months ago
Keen to emphasize success what you're
seeing now is incredible progress being
made but if that was then
this is now
demolition complete but delays on this
side we've got the Fantastic world-class
Children's Hospital which is going to be
a wonderful Hospital the chief executive
excited about prospects but Keen for
Progress we don't have an actual start
date yet because we're waiting for the
green light from government on the
business case for the overall
development we're very keen to move and
we've done a lot of work to prepare and
do all of the enabling Works ahead of
time so that we're in a position to move
as quickly as possible
Sky News understands many others feel
similar a freedom of information request
to each Hospital revealed just 20
percent of the 40 new hospitals have
either been completed or begun
construction work less than a third a
whole new hospitals most of new wings or
refurbishments and 80 percent of the 40
new hospitals say they have either not
been given a completion date or expect
complete in the back half of the decade
there's no sign of these 40 new
hospitals the only place they seem to
exist is in Boris Johnson's imagination
and it's striking that neither Rishi
sunak nor Liz truss are talking about 40
new hospitals either because they know
that they can't be delivered won't be
delivered delivery now the subject of an
investigation the National Audit office
launching a value for money probe into
the program I think it's up to the
National Audit office as an independent
trusted body to be honest with the
public in the way that the Prime
Minister and his ministers haven't been
so just tell us can these even be
delivered if they can at what cost and
if they can at what time frame hospitals
up and down the country waiting to
unlock the full potential of this scheme
a program the government are adamant
they'll deliver as part of their
leveling up agenda Beth Rigby Sky News